eu sei que é jogar e vou falar
moleque e sura fácil mas é só seguir as
mesmas falar com você e você vai saber
quando crescer
acontece que eu cresci
tá certo que nem foi tanto né mas cresci
e os questionamentos e eles continuaram
aos 15 anos de idade
eu entrei no terceiro ano do ensino
médio eu estava completamente perdido
com 19 eu ainda estava no terceiro ano
do ensino médio
pra eu sair do ensino médio eu tive que
fazer aquela prova de supletivo
sabe aquela que a pessoa fala se você
não precisa estudar o ano todo e fazer
todas as provas não vê que faz o é se
você passar de do diploma foi assim
minha mãe professora me influenciou
bastante a fazer vestibulares depois
disso e durante alguns anos eu fiz
vários vestibulares
não me perguntem como mas eu passei seis
vezes
juro que eu não vou lê dessas seis vezes
eu me matriculei em 3
a primeira delas foi em foi eng
não lembro que fui em uma faculdade
federal no curso de engenharia elétrica
desistir no primeiro dia quando eu
peguei o que eu fiz a inscrição eu
peguei aquela folha que falava as
matérias e nem pesquisando no google
entendia muito bem o que era aquilo
ainda perceber que as aulas de manhã e
de tarde por aí fora
nessa época eu já tinha certo
conhecimento de programação de
computadores
eu aprendi isso além de artigos na
internet
nessa época não tinha tanta vídeo aula
tem porque a internet é discada em
tcheca de agradecer a deus quando as
imagens carregavam vídeo nem pensar
então eu peguei pensei vou fazer sistema
de informação que tem mais a ver com
aquilo que é o que eu gosto
entra em cena de informação as notas
estavam muito bem
eu gostava muito dos das pessoas que
estavam comigo mas eu não conseguia
encaixar naquilo que eu não conseguia me
realizar contínuo desistir novamente
muito tempo depois eu entrei no curso de
administração e se eu já fui com um
objetivo em mente o único objetivo que
era arrumar um sócio
quanto ao meu sócio eu saí da faculdade
mas os questionamentos durante esse
tempo foram muitos
eu ficava me perguntando quem é que eu
estou fazendo aqui
será que não tem outra forma de eu dar
certo na vida eu era eu não consegui me
encaixar naquilo essa na verdade era
como tentar pegar ela é como pegar um
elefante tentar colocar na caixa de
fósforo não ia não ia mesmo então eu
comecei a analisar como que as coisas
funcionavam e eu percebi que o sistema
ele é feito para tirar criar pessoas
padrões padrão é como a linha de
montagem que forma as pessoas pra fazer
em um mundo continuar funcionando da
forma que ele é e isso também tem
importância
agora há pessoas que não querem ser uma
engrenagem do mundo como ele é
há pessoas que querem reinventar o mundo
há pessoas que querem transformar o
mundo e vocês acham que o ensino como
ele é nos coloca como protagonistas
dessa transformação
eu particularmente creio que não
eu pesquisei e sempre gostei muito de
ler sobre várias pessoas que são
realizador as pessoas que fizeram a
diferença no mundo seja em grande escala
seja pequena escala
eu encontrei pessoas diversas
algumas que nascerem em classe alta
outras na classe muito baixa algumas
delas em cidades muito grandes
outras em cidades muito pique muito
pequenas algumas delas tiveram acesso a
computadores de última geração desde
criança outras somente na fase adulta
todas elas realizaram grandes coisas
algumas delas fizeram ensino formal
fizeram faculdade mestrado doutorado phd
se ea coisa toda
outras nem mesmo fizeram faculdade e
isso me leva a questionar qual era o
ponto em comum entre essas pessoas que
realizaram que reinventaram o mundo e eu
entendi que essas pessoas ela tinha uma
capacidade muito grande de aprender por
si só ela tinha uma capacidade muito
grande de um aprendizado prático e aí eu
comecei diferenciar o que é educação do
que era escolaridade
a escolaridade é uma parte muito pequena
da educação
a educação é o tudo eu costumo dizer que
o sistema formal
ele funciona assim é como você pegar um
pássaro e colocar dentro de uma gaiola
você coloca o alimento e água pra ele
já a alta educação é um pássaro livre
ele aprendi observando mas as fontes que
são melhores para que ele vá beber água
ele ali ele se alimenta de acordo as
próprias necessidades
durante o caminho dele e eu sempre fui
uma pessoa que lhe muito ele coisas
muito diversas
eu leio desde aquela revista lá no
consultório médico até livros mais
densos de assuntos como psicologia
comportamento humano e várias coisas
eu gosto de saber como as coisas
funcionam eu gosto de saber porquê de as
pessoas fazerem o que elas fazem eu
gosto de ver
não é como aconteceu às histórias das
pessoas e quando quando a gente fala
sobre isso a gente percebe que essas
pessoas que reinventam o mundo
elas têm se essa ligação com a vida e
com as situações que ela passa ela
aprende não pelo que te passam mas elas
se transformam para depois transformar o
mundo e nesse sentido eu percebi o
seguinte eu precisava me transformar
para depois transformar o mundo num dos
projetos meus que é um aplicativo de
pedir comida eu percebi que eram
necessárias habilidades e conhecimentos
diversos para que aquele projeto viesse
se tornar realidade
algumas dessas habilidades e
conhecimentos encontrei os meus sócios
outras
eu precisei desenvolver para que ele dê
certo lembrou que mandela se de uma das
minhas responsabilidades a lei era fazer
o marketing já tinha certo conhecimento
da área mas o que eu fiz pra que aquilo
se tornasse realidade
eu aprendi com essa observação das
pessoas que fazem o seguinte eu
precisava me dizem se desvenciliar de
todos aqueles outros conhecimentos e
focar única e exclusivamente uma coisa
em aprender aquele assunto em específico
que o príncipe precisava para ter um
momento eu precisava beber de uma fonte
específica para aquilo então eu comecei
a reunir todo e qualquer conteúdo que eu
via valor dessa área específica cases de
sucesso pessoas que fizeram acontecer
nessa área eu juntei tudo eu mergulhei
naquele conteúdo
mas o mergulho de uma forma muito
profunda e eu percebi que quanto mais
profunda mergulhava mas eu trazia
pérolas valiosas para a superfície e
essas pérolas eram os princípios que
essas pessoas utilizaram para fazer o
que elas fizeram
então eu comecei a ge ea criar os planos
de acordo os princípios que eu aprendi e
não de acordo simplesmente do passo a
passo e quando a gente começa a ligar as
coisas aos princípios que dão certo eu
vi que as coisas começaram a andar de
uma maneira diferente começará a ser
realizados assim como essas pessoas que
eu vinha realizando
então aqui eu questiono essa foi a forma
que eu utilizei e que eu utilizo tanto
os meus negócios quanto na minha vida
pessoal e tem dado certo pra mim mas eu
questiono pra você qual a forma que dá
certo pra você nem sempre a forma que dá
certo é uma pessoa que dá certo para
outra pessoa
cada pessoa tem uma forma de ver a vida
de transformar o mundo e de impactar as
pessoas qual é a sua conhecimento
ele é prático ele deve ser ele deve ser
praticado
o conhecimento ele não é simplesmente
uma moeda social onde é melhor quem tem
mais o conhecimento é se uma ferramenta
social onde ganha mais quem compartilha
conhecimento é prático reinventar o
mundo é você criar soluções que impacta
a vida das pessoas é você transformar a
forma que as pessoas vivem se relacionam
compram vendem a forma que elas são
impactar as pessoas como um todo é
quebrar todos os padrões e ser diferente
é fazer diferente para fazer a diferença
o convite é muito simples é nos
transformarmos por dentro o nosso mundo
pra aí sim transformar o mundo de fora o
baile
[Aplausos]